uh r.i.p jack knight jack knight was a
very very funny talented kid man
stand-up comedian voice actor writer
um
yeah just like uh i mean i didn't know
jack too well like you know we would say
hello when we met each other we'd
correspond on instagram and share you
probably knew him a little bit i knew a
little better but like we weren't so we
weren't super close whenever we saw each
other we both just had a lot of love for
each other i always loved this kid he
was young he was 28 yeah and he was just
so
full of light dude that's the only way i
can describe it you would just see him
and you'd just be like man this kid is
just full of light he's so talented so
funny so cool yeah and again i'm not
close to them at all so maybe the people
close to him knew that he was you know
you know had some demons etc yeah and
but this is one of those from the
outside
where it was like this is very shocking
and comic suicide is not very shocking
because you you especially if there's
like some comics out there who are
constantly you know sad depressed etc
you're like okay i could see why that
happened but from i did not expect this
at all
at all from that yeah but again i don't
know him that well maybe the people
close to him are like yeah you know he
had uh he had some real real mental
issues yeah
it was sad um sad for me so whoever was
really good friends of him it's up to
y'all
yeah yeah i know i know sam is close i
know langston is close yeah sir isaiah
shouts of love to y'all and then loves
to jack and his family like what yeah
i'm gonna miss that kid man yeah he was
a [ __ ] good kid yeah man r.i.p r.i.p
jack knight love you buddy